I was saying we're watching some of your
stand-up Clips I was like I like this
guy you have like good energy I was like
even I was like it feels like you're
doing stand-up because you like to do
stand up and you wanted to stand up not
doing it as a means to just get more
views on your stuff or not doing it as a
means to just be like oh everyone does
stand up now I feel like everybody does
stand up now and everybody acts now it's
like everybody just thinks everybody
just does everything I did stand up
before everything that's what I'm saying
so I could tell your energy was was good
I was like he seems like he's you know
he's not like so like erratic you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was good you
were calm I like this man I mean not
that my opinion matters I don't [__]
know anything dude yeah I want tips from
you I don't know what to do well okay
let's start with this only crowd work
okay it's no more writing only cry I
thought he was saying like that's a new
site like only fans yeah yeah only the
crowd work yeah yeah you sign up you get
butt naked yeah you get butt naked you
see you've seen that show going around
on Instagram the naked comedy show no
yeah Comics just get naked and the
audience is naked Society seems like
it's in a good place yeah it seems like
people are mentally healthy yeah and um
wow I don't have that confidence either
confidence up there me dude my penis
doesn't even go past my balls yeah
you know no I you don't want to see that
it looks like I have three balls yeah
and so I don't want to do that you know
and I don't that's another thing like if
I didn't have kids maybe but it's like I
don't need my kids to see a picture of
my [__] you know my my literal penis
that looks like a half a thumb yeah I
don't need that you have a son right I
do have a stepson so stepson yeah got it
stepson good kid my stepson Lefty yeah
um oh I was just gonna say if you saw
your three balls right but it was your
biological he'd be like oh damn
yeah but if he's a step maybe he'll
enjoy it more because he's like yeah
yeah at least I didn't get that duck
that yeah yeah I know his dad's got a
[__] monster [__] so you think so oh
sh I've been told about it yeah and um
so that's at least that's nice you know
yeah that's always fun isn't it talking
to your lady about her ex oh sure yeah
why the hell not it doesn't at the end
of the day when you have kids and you
know and you get to my age where it's
like you kind of just like I don't care
I remember like I used to ask girls like
when I was younger like how many guys
did you hook up with and then like now
it's like dude great the more the
merrier bring them in here what's over
the fists I don't care dude I don't want
to do it I'm exhausted I don't want to
have sex with her so if she needs to be
satisfied by you then just [__] do it
man please as long as she gets the kids
to school and I could sleep in a little
bit I I really I don't care yeah like
that's the thing I've always thought
with cooking is I think it's a young guy
thing to hate on it yes exactly I knew a
little but then yeah you get old enough
and you're like she wants to have fun
yeah it's not about when you have it's
like it's not about sex I don't care
about that it's like we're trying to I'm
trying to get these kids to eat their
[__] chicken fingers and get to
school and do the homework I don't want
to do the homework you have to so it's
like we're partnering up here yeah I
don't care yeah I don't it's not about
sex I don't care who you're having sex
dude have sex with that I don't care
just as long as the kids work is done
and then I can you know and then you
just start you just allow me to like
just take a few hours for myself I just
want to watch football that's a crazy
ass image of your the mother of your
children in the next room with her dream
guy yeah and you're in the kitchen and
you're like okay it's d-i-n-o yeah
s-a-u-r great great video games yeah NFL
oh no dude that'd be if I didn't you
know if I didn't have to deal with that
I mean because that's what it is you
know you get home it's like listen dude
I've been in La now for what five days
so of course you know five days away
from the family it's tough but it's like
what's the Silver Lining it's like I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm alone in a hotel room so
it's like you jerk off all day so it's
like what it's it's something I can't do
when I'm home when I get home I gotta
get you out of this cycle you're in dude
dude when I get home it's like I don't I
won't again I'm 39 I won't be able to
make a drop of come till Christmas yeah
so I can't have sex with you and then
what's gonna happen she's like what are
you where are you hooking up you know
why don't you wanna have man I'm like no
no I wasn't no I was jerking off to
SportsCenter because I don't
can't jerk off in the house because
there's too many kids we have too many
kids so in a motel room in Lawrence
Kansas exactly so it's like but you know
girls don't understand that so it'd be
nice to just have another guy come in
and just fulfill that so I can just you
know so we can just go ahead I want to
have and be the family you're meant to
be exactly let's have a nice little
family dinner we'll go to Applebee's
wherever you want to go and I want to
I'll talk to the kids and you know
that's it I'll tell him I met [__] is
it Noel yeah it's Noel I like that yeah
[__] I like that dude it's Christmasy
thank you yeah it's I like that yeah
I like I like um and are you do you
celebrate Christmas in your culture
take a guess of my culture Chris
I feel like all Canadians got to do
Christmas
are you really no
this is all right shout out yeah we
celebrate Christmas in like a capitalist
way okay we just like you know we like
that December 1st just buying [__] to
open for ourselves me and the wife right
because we don't have kids yet right so
we kind of we're taking advantage you
guys trying though
we're like
we're kind of in the if we oopsed one
that's I think where we get it going but
you're dropping loads in there oh yeah
okay yeah oh bro I haven't used the
condom in
good dude yeah that's what it's about
yeah you know Stone raw yeah yeah I
think I almost feel like sex with a
condom isn't you're not having sex with
the person you're having sex with the
condom inside of the person yeah you
might as well just masturbate that yeah
if you're gonna have sex have sex like
get get in there get risky yeah oh what
if I get an STD what if I get pregnant
yeah that's how do you think I come yeah
the risk of that yeah what do you think
I'm doing here yeah so you know condoms
kids if you're listening you know get
rid of them yeah yeah all that safe sex
stuff it's [__] dude it's another
more conspiracies from the government
yeah just chlamydia is not real it ain't
hey it's not if you're burning if you're
if it's hot when you pee that means you
did a good job by the way he it is real
I've had it seven times it's not that
big of a deal it's seriously it's like
strep throat for your dick get over it
takes a couple of antibiotics on some
JoJo siwa on relax
does Chlamydia make like dick boogers
like you have mucus is it like
bronchitis down there it's just you know
it's just it's one of those things now
where you know again the beautiful part
about being in a you know in a
relationship a faithful relationship is
you don't worry about that stuff yeah
that is true though that first time you
had sex
at least for us it was like I I have HIV
I'm gonna die dude the very first time I
had sex the very I'm talking about the
very first time I had sex I didn't use a
condom and fully came inside the girl
wow like number one 17 years old right
out of the gate full shot in there let's
go riddled with anxiety possible
pregnancies possible STD yeah just
[__] let her rip yeah number one and
nothing cheap um she uh didn't get
pregnant didn't get an STD she dumped me
about two weeks later because since you
finished too quickly yeah because it was
three pumps and I fully blew a load
inside of her and she was like you know
she was 19 I was 17 which is I think uh
New York not illegal but I will still
press charges and um and and and uh we
should go get her man what the [__] I
don't know she's dead okay
kidding me she's dead she fights she's
in Ukraine yeah um yeah
front lines baby fighting a good fight
you guys have zelenski on yet no we're
thinking the Pod rounds you see I
thought that guy was going to get killed
a year ago everyone was like this guy's
gonna die he's in the [__] Comfort
Time Magazine he's probably gonna
Superstar he's out here doing I'm I
guarantee he comes and does pods yeah
he'll be on flagrant next oh yeah dude
yeah can't wait
laughs